all right this one's a little bit on the
longer side so I'm just gonna I'm just
going to read it in its entirety
when discussing Mad Max and Nita said
that she doesn't think it's very
feminist because violence is inherently
a tool of masculinity used to oppress I
think Mad Max fury road has some pretty
feminist themes which is awesome but I'm
also a pacifist and interested in and
use arguments what are your thoughts my
thoughts when it comes to the subject of
is Mad Max feminist I think that this is
ultimately the wrong question to ask
because and this goes for anything when
you're looking at you know is such and
such is is thing feminist you are you
are asking the wrong question because
nothing will ever truly manage to pass
that hurdle
nothing will be pure enough to to be you
know properly 100% thoroughly feminist
and this goes for any ideology and
that's why the stuff that does manage to
conform to ideology lockstep beginning
to end and contains no no elements that
would be considered problematic or
contradictory that's why we call that
stuff propaganda because it it exists
purely to espouse ideology and to be
pure to an ideology storytelling is
inherently messy storytelling is
inherently conflict driven or at least
our forms of storytelling you know the
the Anglo spheres forms of storytelling
are rooted in conflict and that need for
conflict in our narratives is is
antithetical and is in is in direct
contradiction and conflict with
ideological purity and so when you're
saying like does Mad Max fury road have
feminist themes does it have some
feminist values does it reflect the kind
of creating the feminists would like to
see more of the answer is yes absolutely
is Mad Max fury road feminist
oh it can't be asking that question
repeatedly and demanding that level of
ideological purity distracts from you
know both more important questions and
more practical questions like how can we
make movies more friendly to female
audiences how can we make movies less
alienating how can we make movies less
racist as always the best way to reach
me for a question is through ask fm
or Twitter links down below in the
description